[Music]
i don't write as much as i'd like
because the words are never perfect how
do i put an end to my perfectionism
um
define perfect word i mean it's
perfectionism
uh somebody told me this comedian told
me this he said perfectionism is not
wanting things to be perfect perfection
and perfectionism is having an
impossible standard that will always
make you miserable doing your work
um they're like
i mean forget about all these like
there's no you know all the memes of
like there's no such thing as perfection
like perfect words i mean what are you
talking about you know that's crazy
there's words are just words it's like
i'm waiting for the perfect weather well
good luck you know weather changes all
the time what you're doing as a writer
is you're channeling the currency of
energy and life that's happening through
you in any given moment and you're
trying to contain it in a story and a
paragraph into whatever and that's why
when you go back to the page the next
day you change it you know because
there's a different thing happening and
that's cool that's fine and what you are
doing as a writer is you're actually
curating all these moments that you've
been encountering over the course of a
month or three months or six months or
nine months
and you've got to
find a way to contain that process for
you and your process is not my process
you ever heard that uh uh um
maxim that says there are three rules
for writing
unfortunately nobody knows what they are
right you know it's like no no this is
the way it works and it's like but this
guy does it over here completely
differently you know
you have to find your own madness
and for me i know that i don't write a
better book in 18 months that i write in
six books six months but i know that if
i try to write it in one month it's not
as good like i know kind of what my
threshold is for
good i'm not trying to get too perfect
i'm trying to get to
something that is better than the last
thing i did so that i know that i'm
growing and i always try to take on
projects that i don't know i can do
right because that's how i'm gonna i'm
gonna grow into it i'm gonna step into
it
um
and there's an old because we were
getting all biblical there was an old
bible story about the prophet samuel who
um
got a new coat at the beginning of every
year and if you think about this what he
was as a boy and he was kind of coming
up studying under you know this this
other uh prophet and he was learning how
to be a holy man basically and you know
once a year he got a new coat now how
big did that coat have to be
if it fit him the day he tried as a boy
the day he tried it on he wouldn't be
able to wear it all here and so he had
to get a bigger coat and this is how we
ought to choose creative projects we
should always be
putting on a coat that's about a year
ahead of us so that by the end of the
year it fits you know what i'm saying
pick projects pick endeavors that you
don't know that you can do i mean for
perfectionism i don't know what planet
you're on yeah like
find a vision to create something that
excites you and you go i don't know if i
can do this awesome
and then figure out the words that you
need to fit into that container to make
it happen so that by the end of it you
go i didn't know that i could do it
wonderful
perfect words don't exist words exist
and be like shakespeare if you can't
find the right words just make them up
like he just made up words yeah you know
or trump shakespeare trump that same
thing
makes stuff up
and and but like if you're if you're if
you're messing with words you're stuck
in the details the vision is how do i
make something that excites me and i
don't know if i could do it you see a
problem in the world that nobody is
solving and you go i want to try to
solve that problem that's what we mean
when we say add value it's like
somebody's not talking about this
somebody's not doing it or they're not
doing it the way that i would do it cool
try it and hopefully you fail a few
times so that tells you you're trying
things that are bigger than you can do
if you spend your whole life doing
things that you're comfortable with
this boring yeah you're not growing
you've just given me like a whole new
perspective on perfectionism because
there's no perfect
but
you know
on the same on the other side of the
coin there's no such thing as imperfect
perfect
the etymology of perfect in in kind of
middle english um means complete
yeah there's a difference between
perfection and pristine
yeah
make your work complete not pristine not
flawless what are you talking about
flawless you walk down the street and
you're like these trees are asymmetrical
no you're crazy perfection is an idea
that you invented to make yourself
unhappy with the work that you're going
to do
so
stop it start doing work that is
complete how do you know it's complete
because you finished it yeah you know
leonardo da vinci says
all
uh what does he say he says art is never
finished only abandoned right and
there's two ways to abandon art one is
you don't complete it the other is you
go god this could be so much better and
i'm so afraid
and i'm gonna call it done i'm gonna put
it out into the world and i'm gonna
learn from this experience of completing
this so i can go do the next one this is
the best thing i could do given the time
and resources i had right i want to talk
about there's sort of perfectionism here
from two perspectives and i think they
both
stem from the same source i think there
are people who
suffer from perfectionism and i think
there are people who thrive in spite of
their perfectionism and when i talk
about earlier on the private podcast
here while we are
i'm very detail-oriented and
i those details help me thrive as long
as i don't get too bogged down into it
i'm trying to perfect everything now i
will challenge you on one thing uh
although i do think perfection is
perspectival to a great extent you
talked about the perfect weather well
according to whom right of course like
to me it's like 72 and sunny and ryan
it's like cloudy and rainy right exactly
60 60-inch snow base with some like you
know 12 or 13 inches on top of fluff
that's perfect weather for me
and so it is perspectival in that
respect but then i would say the same
thing with like writing if i read a don
delillo novel i can't
get past a few pages because it's like
reading a painting i know and and so
like you just get stuck how and then you
realize how he does it is he's quite the
perfectionist as well he types one
paragraph at a time on a typewriter
even if the sentence is one
pair just one
one pair one sentence per paragraph he
types it out and that's one page and he
sets it aside and he's looking how do
the words look relative to the other
words in the sentence
and by the end of a novel he has an
entire sort of book of these individual
paintings every sentence is like a
painting
and
that's something that i aspire toward
quite often but also realize that all of
his resources go into
writing the sentence by the way there's
very little plot in what he does it's
just
pictures yeah yeah it's pictures that
move you through to the to the end of
the book
and not a whole lot happens
but it's beautiful the whole time now
also to me aesthetics mean a whole lot
more than ideas do
and so the aesthetic of the sentence
really resonates with me more than like
trying to communicate some grand idea so
that's my idea of perfect someone else
might open up
the body artist and and and say what the
hell is this this is going no of course
they do yeah yeah you know i i taught
online courses for years and um people
would always go is this good
you know and i would just basically say
to whom yeah you know like uh and what
does it mean to be good
uh you know i
i love hemingway people think he's
terrible you know uh or um you might
like harry potter you know this is
brilliant you know like what is it
you could be a literary writer you could
be a genre writer and it's like good to
whom what does that mean when i hear
when i hear what you're describing i
think you have standards yeah and your
standards aren't my standards yeah just
like when we walk through an art museum
it's like
wow i like some of this i don't like
other things i kind of understand this i
don't understand it and 10 years later i
walk through and i like other things yes
and it's like uh cool
hearing you talk about that i had a
friend
who
uh
lived on the property of cormac
mccarthy's editor
and he one day he asked
the guy who who owned this land and my
friend was the like the groundskeeper
for cormac mccarthy's editor and he said
um
what is it like you know and he saw he
saw some pages on his desk and he goes
what's it like working with you know
editing cormac mccarthy he goes if i get
through a paragraph it's a good day
and it's like that's just that's his
craft yeah you know and i don't one is
not better than the other cormac
mccarthy is not trying to be jk rowling
yeah right she's a billionaire he's not
who's right i don't know like
both of those works because of their
significance to culture both of the
works of these artists will live on for
probably the next hundred years for
different reasons that's right yeah and
that's okay so that's your vision know
what you're trying to create yes
understand i think it was dan pink who
said that um mastery is an asymptote
which is you know when's the last time
you heard that
seventh grade math or something an
asymptote is like imagine a graph where
you have this line that consistently
gets closer and closer to an axis to
another line but never touches it yeah
it's that old math problem of like if a
frog left half the length of the pier
and a half and a half he'd never get to
the end well that's mastery mastery is
getting closer and closer to an ideal
this is kind of this old western greek
concept that there are these ideals of
beauty and and the projection of that
ideal is art there's an ideal of uh you
know justice and and our legal system is
an imperfect representation of that and
we're always as human beings trying to
get closer and closer to the ideal
and that could be your that can that can
kill an artist yeah if you're like it's
not good enough
or it can enliven you because you're
constantly
getting better at and better at your
craft uh you know what what is i can't
remember like but so it's a progression
of greatness towards a worthy goal and
there's like a victor frankel thing in
there somewhere but like happiness
actually comes from us trying to do
something
great and never quite getting exactly
there and every attempt is better you
know and
yeah it can be maddening or enlivening
depending on your perspective but
everybody's got different standards and
our job as artists is to know what those
standards are
because i because you're not competing
with everybody but you're competing with
people who share your standards if you
read an author and you go i would love
to do that good
right like that gives you a reason to
get up tomorrow and try harder yeah you
said that you know the artist needs to
focus on what they want to create maybe
another way to look at it is what do
they want to communicate and instead of
asking themselves like is this work
perfect is this is is this as good as it
can be the question is are you
communicating as clearly as possible
what you're trying to communicate i
asked a friend one time well my writing
coach marion roach smith wonderful
author um wrote a great book called the
memoir project if anybody ever wants to
write memoir i would highly recommend
that very short book she's a brilliant
writer um and she um i said i was
working on this book actually and it was
every book takes me i just mentioned you
know like i can't do it in one month but
i can do it in six months and i've
written five books under my own name and
about a dozen plus you know including
ghost written books and um every book
takes me twice as long as the previous
book because my standards keep going up
you know i can't i don't want to write
that book again i want to write
something better
and i asked her i was about i don't know
in the third or fourth developmental
edit of this book go and i said um how
do i know when i'm done um you know
because i could add this story or change
this or do that she said you you're done
when when you've made your argument um
like
like think of it as like uh like you're
in court as a lawyer going back to
lawyer this this episode is brought to
you by um legalzoom
and um when you rest when you make your
case
and the reader is the jury and the judge
and they get sometimes the executioner
and they get to decide
if you convinced them that's the hard
part of making anything is of course you
go into it with an idea an argument a
message something that you want to
change and then you try to put it into
this thing and people screw it up man
like they get other things out of it you
know and they they read words in there
that you never wrote
and your job is to make your case make
your argument and then rest and go
have fun and and you know as liz gilbert
says once you release it it no longer
belongs to you it belongs to this cosmic
craziness where people
pick up all kinds of things that you
never meant to say yeah and that's
that's that's beautiful it can be really
beautiful i think perfectionism often
stems
from
fear of some sort and so fear of
being thought of in a way fear of being
rejected fear of failure but we're
defining all of these things based on
some you know predetermined
bias that we picked up along the way
right and so if i
don't
do the thing if i don't write then i
can't fail at being a writer right i can
be the perfect writer in my head and i
think that's the the essence of
jeffrey's question here like yeah you're
a perfect writer until you start writing
yeah
and then you have to change your
definition of perfection you have to
move from pristine to complete did i do
the best that i knew how to do with the
time and resources that i had today then
you rest you go you know your honor the
defense rests and tomorrow is a
different day with different
circumstances yeah alan watts says the
key to fear is to not be afraid of it
and so i think that's really the way
that you overcome perfectionism
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
theminimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free